you had another viral moment it might  not be you but it you know it was your  nephew oh yeah meeting Dak and his  favorite quarterback is that but he he  nervously mistook him from Patrick if  you if you know my nephew he might have  been trying to be funny because my  nephew has like such a big personality  if you just have a conversation with him  he could have been just trying to be  funny like in that moment because but he  is still a little kid so you never know  but I've been around him and he say like  little slick stuff to me and I'm like  well I'll beat you up type Bob so uh  he's definitely one of those kids that  big personality he needs to he needs to  be on a podcast at one point he needs to  have a conversation because he has a lot  to say he's respectful and that's my  little man I might have to beat him up  still but that's my little man